La historia nos ha demostrado que en ocasiones
lo imposible se hace realidad, Mihail Gorbachov
pasó de dirigir la mismísima Unión Soviética
a convertirse en la imagen de toda una multinacional
norteamericana .
¿Veremos algún día algo así en Corea del
Norte? Atentos.
Corea del Norte es un país muy, pero que
muy pobre.
Las estimaciones disponibles dicen que el
valor de su producción per cápita es 50
veces más pequeña que la de Corea del Sur;
menos de 1.000 km de carreteras están pavimentadas;
la esperanza media de vida es la más pequeña
de la región y a pesar de llevar más de
22 años recibiendo ayuda humanitaria la pobreza
está generalizada
Pero...no, nada de eso es lo peor.
Lo peor de todo es la falta total de respeto
por los derechos humanos.
Lo sabemos, los norcoreanos viven sometidos
a una férrea dictadura, a un estado policial
donde los presos políticos se cuentan por
decenas y decenas de miles.
De hecho, según Naciones Unidas entre 80.000
y 120.000 presos políticos podrían estar
en campos de “reeducación”.
En Corea del Norte, amigos, el Estado lo controla
todo.
Sin embargo, esperad un momento... porque
en los últimos años parece estar produciéndose
un importante cambio en este país. Un cambio
que tiene mucho que ver con el dinero,
el comercio y el mercado.
Veréis, en teoría en Corea del Norte, el
último gran país comunista
[bueno…, estado socialista que prepara la
transición comunista, como le gusta decir
a los puristas… y que realmente no suele
significar nada más que una mala justificación
del fracaso]
todo, prácticamente todo es dirigido, organizado,
fabricado y proporcionado por el Estado: vivienda,
salud, educación, alimentación, empleo…
Pero... amigos, esto es la teoría. La realidad
es… diferente.
Mirad, el sistema estatal tiene muchas limitaciones…
por decirlo de alguna manera, cada vez es
menos capaz de hacer nada.
Me explico: muchas de la fábricas y granjas
estatales tienen unos niveles de productividad
que están por los suelos.
(Y no solo eso. En muchos casos, fruto de
una maquinaria muy vieja, de métodos de producción
atrasados, de las sanciones internacionales
e, incluso, de problemas de suministro eléctrico,
durante gran parte del tiempo estos centros
de producción ni siquiera son operativos.)
Por todo esto, en los últimos años ha cobrado
peso una nueva economía privada, de la cual
cada vez más norcoreanos dependen para sobrevivir
y tratar de mejorar su pobre nivel de vida.
[Un momento. ¿Economía privada en Corea
del Norte? ¿Mercados? ¿Capitalismo?]
Pues… tal cual como lo escucháis.
Atentos
(EL NUEVO MERCADO NORCOREANO)
Amigos, cuando Kim Jong-un fue declarado oficialmente
como “líder supremo” [=dictador absoluto]
de Corea del Norte , el 28 de diciembre de
2011, muchos analistas pensaron que las cosas
podían cambiar.
Al fin y al cabo se trataba de un cambio generacional
con el cual llegaba al poder una persona de
apenas 28 años que se había educado en el
extranjero, ni más ni menos que en Suiza.
Sin embargo… pronto quedó claro que algunas
cosas no iban a cambiar. El nuevo líder,
Kim Jong-un ha resultado ser igual de terrible
que lo fue su padre:
Las purgas, los castigos inhumanos, la persecución
de la discrepancia, el culto al líder y,
en definitiva, el control total han continuado
siendo las características fundamentales
de este régimen.
(“Es como una religión. Desde el nacimiento,
aprendes sobre la familia Kim, aprendes que
son dioses, que debes ser absolutamente obediente.
Las élites son tratadas amablemente, y por
eso se aseguran de que el sistema permanezca
estable. Pero para todos los demás, es un
reino del terror.” Hyesan, un médico de
42 años que logró escapar de Corea del Norte
en 2014.)
Sin embargo, amigos, desde que Kim Jong-un
llegó al poder se ha producido algo sorprendente:
decenas de mercados donde los norcoreanos
comercian de forma privada, se convierten
en empresarios, se han abierto por todo el
país.
Tal cual como lo escucháis.
Una nueva clase de comerciantes y empresarios
está creciendo… en Corea del Norte.
(De hecho, según el Instituto para la Reunificación
Nacional de Corea, alrededor de 1 millón,
1 millón de personas trabajan directamente
- y en muchos casos de forma casi exclusiva
- en estos mercados, que ya son una de las
principales fuentes de riqueza de este país.)
Ahora bien… puede que te estés preguntando,
¿Pero… cómo surgieron estos mercados?
Pues, amigos, su origen no es el más glamuroso
ni el más feliz.
(Todo comenzó en la década de los 90, cuando
una hambruna causada por los errores del gobierno,
la falta de medios, las condiciones climáticas
y el desplome de la Unión Soviética, causaron
estragos en el país.)
Las estimaciones cifran, ojo, entre 1 y 2
millones las personas que perdieron su vida
por inanición.
En ese momento, cuando los norcoreanos luchaban
por sobrevivir, fue cuando se formaron los
primeros mercados, lugares donde la gente
intercambiaba todo lo que podía para conseguir
recursos con los que comprar alimentos.
("Nos dimos cuenta de que si no hacíamos
nada, moriríamos de hambre, así que empezamos
a comerciar" Joo Yang.)
De repente, decenas y decenas de mercados
aparecieron por todo el país salvando miles
y miles de vidas.
Motivo, precisamente por el cual el régimen
no persiguió como se hubiera esperado este
tipo de actividades privadas.
Kim Jong-il, el padre del actual líder…
fue.. bueno digamos que a veces toleraba estos
mercados y a veces los reprimía.
(Pero desde que llegó Kim Jong-un al poder…
el número de mercados privados se ha multiplicado
y las imágenes de satélite muestran que
no paran de crecer. Ahora el gobierno aprueba,
autoriza, muchos de estos mercados a cambio
de “alquilar” a los comerciantes el espacio
que necesitan.)
Sí, así es, el propio gobierno de Pyongyang
se aprovecha de esta nueva economía privada.
¿Cuánto? Pues según los cálculos del Instituto
para la unificación obtiene más de 220.000 dólares
por día.
Así que, precisamente, por este motivo, en
los últimos tiempos el gobierno no solo está
impulsando estos mercados sino que también
ha concedido visas a muchos empresarios y
comerciantes chinos, precisamente, para impulsar
esta actividad.
Pero aquí, amigos, no termina todo, para
nada. Atentos.
(EL MERCADO “EXTRAOFICIAL”)
No solo la actividad de los mercados regulados
está creciendo, también la de los mercados
extraoficiales, es decir, aquellos que no
cuentan con la aprobación oficial de la autoridad:
el mercado negro.
(Veréis, todo esto funciona de la siguiente
forma: en una economía paralela al sector
público, la gente fabrica todo lo que puede:
zapatos, dulces, ropa… y como es natural
trata de vender estos productos en los mercados
para obtener dinero… a ser posible yuanes
o, incluso, dólares. [Sí, dólares.])
Pero aun así, se calcula que el 80% de los
productos vendidos en los mercados norcoreanos
proceden de China.
Es decir, dicho de otra forma… el comercio
“ilegal”, a espaldas del gobierno también
cruza la frontera, ojo, con volúmenes enormes
y cada vez mayores..
Por cierto, muchos de estos mercados extraoficiales
se están convirtiendo en toda una ventana
al exterior para muchos norcoreanos. Porque
en estos lugares se pueden comprar, incluso,
memorias USB llenas de películas y series
extranjeras, incluidas producciones de Hollywood.
("Cuando veíamos programación extranjera,
teníamos que cerrar todas las puertas y cortinas
y pretender que no había nadie en casa. Danbi
Kim)
Pero… puede que os estéis preguntando…
¿contrabando? ¿Cruzar la frontera? ¿Y qué
pasa con los guardias y los servicios de seguridad?
¿Cómo toleran este comercio ilegal?
Pues… básicamente por dos motivos:
el primero, es que en Pyongyang no parece
existir mucha presión para combatir estos
mercados, ahora veremos por qué.
Y segundo, porque los soldados y guardias
fronterizos forman también parte del negocio…
por ejemplo poniendo la mano.
Sí, así es. Una forma habitual de pago,
según han contado muchos de estos comerciantes
que hoy ya viven fuera de Corea del Norte,
es entregar a los policías y a los soldados
cajetillas de cigarrillos rellenas no de cigarrillos
sino de yuanes, yenes o, incluso dólares.
(Estos comerciantes internacionales compran
productos en los mercados autorizados o en
el mercado negro de Corea del Norte, lo trasladan
a China, lo venden y con ese dinero compran
productos chinos y los llevan a Corea del
Norte para venderlos. El comercio de toda
la vida.)
Y aquí amigos, con este comercio internacional
es donde sí está surgiendo una clase de
personas, generalmente cercanas al poder o
con influencias o tratos con altos funcionarios,
que sí está haciendo dinero… y que, por
cierto, están impulsando en Pyongyang, un
montón de actividades que ya no tienen nada
que ver con el viejo modelo socialista.
(“El salario para los doctores era de unos
3.500 won al mes. Era menos de lo que costaba
comprar un kilo de arroz. Así que, por supuesto,
ser médico no era mi trabajo principal. Mi
trabajo principal era contrabandear de noche.
Enviaba medicina herbaria de Corea del norte
a China, y con el dinero, importaba aparatos
electrodomésticos” Un médico de 42 años
que actualmente vive en Corea del Sur en declaraciones
al Washington Post)
Hoy, por ejemplo, ya es posible comprar Coca
Cola en las calles de Pyongyang, y según
el servicio de inteligencia de Corea del Sur,
al menos el 40% de todos los norcoreanos participan
de algún modo en actividades y negocios privados.
¿Sorprendidos? Pues… aún hay más.
[Pero antes de nada, una nota importante:
amigos, estamos hablando de un proceso aún
muy incipiente.
En Corea del Norte, el gobierno sigue teniendo
el control de prácticamente todo. Si estos
mercados negros están creciendo es porque
en Pyongyang lo están permitiendo porque
son más eficientes, funcionan mejor, les
permite obtener divisas y muchos norcoreanos
encuentran un modo de mejorar sus pésimos
niveles de vida. Algo similar pasó en la
Unión Soviética, en Vietnam y por supuesto
en China.]
Ahora sí, veamos que está ocurriendo.
¿REFORMAS MADE IN CHINA?
Toda esta nueva clase de comerciantes y empresarios
que está emergiendo, tiene un nombre entre
los norcoreanos: donju.
Y, como os podéis imaginar, muchos de ellos,
especialmente los que de verdad hacen dinero
son personas del Partido Comunista y bien
conectadas con el gobierno.
Es decir, forman parte de la élite… situación
que aprovechan no solo para tener un trato
especial por parte de las fuerzas de seguridad…
sino también para llegar a acuerdos ventajosos
con las empresas públicas.
Sí, así es, hay claras sospechas de que
muchas exportaciones “irregulares” son
fabricadas en empresas públicas… pero los
beneficios van a parar e estos miembros de
la élite.
(Ahora bien, este nuevo “planteamiento”
económico no es algo que moleste en el gobierno
de Pyongyang. De hecho, todo apunta a que
el gobierno norcoreano quiere reproducir de
alguna manera el modelo chino:
Es decir, buscar inversión extranjera que
les permita crecer y desarrollarse, pero sin
perder el control político.)
Fijaos, desde que Kim Jong-un llegó al poder,
su gobierno ha concedido más libertad a las
empresas públicas para que puedan organizarse
como les convenga, buscar sus propios proveedores
y clientes.
También ha impulsado, como hemos visto, los
mercados privados, hace la vista gorda con
el mercado negro y las familias en las granjas
colectivas tienen ahora asignadas parcelas
individuales cuya cosecha, una vez que cumplen
con la cuota estatal, pueden utilizar como
quieran, pueden por ejemplo, venderla en los mercados
privados.
Incluso se empieza a hablar de zonas económicas
especiales.
Pero, insisto amigos, este es un proceso aún
muy incipiente.
(No se trata de que se vaya a producir un
cambio radical en el corto plazo sino que
ante la incapacidad del sistema oficial los
norcoreanos están desarrollando una alternativa
que mejore su pobre nivel de vida.
Desgraciadamente, Corea del Norte sigue siendo
el mismo país totalitario y pobre que era
antes de la llegada de Kim Jong-un. Y aun
peor, las actuales sanciones internacionales
están causando enormes estragos en las ya
de por sí escasas capacidades productivas
del país.)
Aun con todo no me diréis que el crecimiento
de esta nueva especie de economía paralela
no es algo sorprendente.
Pero ahora, turno para ti. ¿Crees que Corea
del Norte tratará de seguir el modelo chino?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta. Si te ha resultado
interesante el vídeo dale a like y no olvides
suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.